hi everyone my name is Freddy and I'm
one of the engineers at
gradio um a couple weeks ago gradio
released version 4.0 which comes with a
lot of really cool new updates to the
gradio library all focus on making
gradio much more customizable and
extensible than it was in the past uh
one of the coolest things that came with
4.0 is the ability to create your own
custom gradio component uh so what I
wanted to do today with you is go
through a live coding session of
creating um a custom component so that
you can get a feel for how to do it
yourself um yeah so for this example uh
we'll be creating a a take we'll be
creating our own version of the gradio
Chapa component uh that's uh focus on
multimodal applications so you'll be
able to return messages and send
messages that contain both text and
media like images files and videos um so
you know without much further Ado uh
let's get started really excited um so
today what I want to do is uh walk
through an example of how you would
build your own uh multimodal chatbot
component so the gradio chatbot
component can already display images so
it already is multimodal uh but it can't
inter leave uh text and media components
um so you have to send uh like a video
or an image and a separate message from
the text um and I want to build the chat
bot that can show the same the text and
the media the media and the same message
um so that's what we're going to do
today um so the first step to creating a
custom component is to install gradio
4.0
so uh let me just uh PP show
gradio so I'm using gradio 4.1.1 here
any gradio 4.0 version should should
work uh for this case Okay so the first
step uh after that is to create the
scaffolding for your custom component so
in gradio 4.0 there is a gradio cc
command line tool uh CC stands for
custom components and then it comes with
a certain set of commands that you can
use to bootstrap your custom component
uh so the one that we're going to use
here it's the the build uh the uh no
sorry the create command the create
command you know creates a new component
for you so radio CC create and then I'm
going to call it
multimodal
chatbot uh and then the template and
then you you can pass it a template
which is like uh an existing component
to build off off so in this case it's
very natural to build off of the the
chatbot component so I'm going to run
that um okay so it's going to you know
create the backend code some front end
code install python install uh install
the JavaScript dependencies all that
good
stuff just give it a second
here cool so that all worked so what
that did is it created a multimodal
chatbot directory which I'm going to
open in vs code uh which is right here
cool um
so if we look at um the directory
structure there's three parts there's
the back end the front end uh and the
demo the demo is like a demo you can use
to test out your component and then
obviously the backend and front end
contain the backend and front end code
uh cool it creates a read me for you um
a p project tommo file that has like the
your project config um there's a couple
Fields here that you can uh you can fill
in if you want to so Freddy Bolton then
my email in this case will be uh
Freddy huggingface
face. um and then you can you know add
some keywords some you know all that
good stuff uh if you have dependencies
you can add them here but in this case
Gro is the only dependency we need cool
so let's get started uh I'm going to
start off with the back end so I'm I'm
more of a python developer um but you
don't need to be a front-end expert to
get started building custom components
specifically or especially when you
template off an existing component um a
lot of the work is already done for you
so what I'm going to do is I'm just
going to delete some of this stuff so
what gradio what templating does it
literally pulls in the chatot component
from the gradio library so there's some
gradio specific stuff here that we don't
need for our case like this like Auto
documentation stuff um cool but uh
everything else sorry everything else
looks good to me so the first thing that
you do when you design uh design a
custom component is think about the data
model so the data model is something
that's new in gradio
4.0 uh but it basically encapsulates the
data that you're going to be sending to
the front end and the data that the
front end is going to be sending to your
component um so as you know as we can
see here the chatbot data um it's a list
of tupal and the Tuple is either the
element of the tup is either a string or
a file right so you know that kind of
says what the what the problem in my
mind that with the original chap not the
problem or like the thing that we want
to change is that rather than having a
string or a file message we want to have
you know one data one piece of data and
capsulate both um so that's that's what
we're going to do um so we're going to
keep the file message the same what
we're going to
do uh class uh multimodal message or
multimodal chat but data I think that
looks good uh so what this will be is
that it'll be a oh sorry this will be a
gradio
model uh this will be a text so it'll be
a string and it'll be a a list of files
so it'll be
list file
message um and then these things can be
optional uh
yes
cool and then in our chatbot data what
we're going to do is this will be a
tupal of the Union
of basically it'll be
optional uh multimodal I think I'm going
to change this to multimodal message
multimodal
message
okay multi modal message and then this
will
be optional multimodal message cool so
what this is saying is that the chatbot
data is going to be a list of tupal and
the tupal will be consist of you know a
pair of multimodal messages either one
can be
none okay so that pretty much that's
almost the hardest part okay so now um
every gradio component has a
pre-process and postprocess
um method so what this does is that it
or so let's look at pre-process first
what this does is it'll take the payload
which is the data that we get from the
front end in this case it's the chatbot
data uh and it'll turn it into the data
that your prediction function is
supposed to receive so uh in this case
it'll turn the chap dat into a list of
lists and all that stuff um but I don't
actually um for this case I don't think
we need to to do all that I think we
could just pass the chatbot data to the
actual python function or prediction
function uh that will uh use this
component
so um what we're going to do is actually
let's look at pre-processed chat
message um
okay cool cool cool
so
yeah so this is what we're going to do
we're going to do a this will return
payload chapot data so chapot data or
none and this will return a chapot data
or none so the payload is none we do
that that's good um and
then uh what we're going to do is oh
actually what we can do is we'll just
return a list of multimodel chat message
or multimodel message let's do that okay
so uh we don't need that I think so for
message pair in
payload.bin clean doc so what we're
going to do uh so message
pair uh uh for message
pair oh actually you
know it um okay yeah so what is this
going to do Post process
preprocess preprocess chat message oh
here we go
calling okay yeah yeah so I don't think
we need any of this so we could
just yeah let's just uh
we'll just
[Music]
return payload root oh
sorry return
payload
Roots um okay that looks good to me and
then we can get rid of this
stuff yeah
okay awesome so now uh let's go to
postprocess so post postprocess um takes
a data returned by the python function
and then turns it into the data that's
going to be sent to the server so what
this is doing um it's uh it's adding a
MIM type to to the file data and it's
also you know cleaning the chat message
uh it's calling clean doc so uh let's do
that okay
so
um so the chat message will be
a multi uh chat no not it would be a
multimodal message
or a
dictionary or none and then this will
return a multimodal
message or none okay so if multimodal
message is none return none if it's a
dictionary what we're going to do is uh
chat
message equals we're going to turn it
into a multimodal message okay
uh
dict is this
right yes it is right okay cool and then
what we're going to do here is uh okay
so then what we're going to do here is
we're just going to call these things
independently or just these things on
the on a chat message so chat
message uh text is going to be
message text and then
uh I don't I don't know what that's
doing
um oh yeah so
for
uh for
file and chat message
files uh
[Music]
file
M type going to
be and I
think that is all we
need
cool and then we're going to
[Music]
return
message
cool looks good to
me uh multi model message that's the
file
uh way sorry what is it multimodal
message a list of
files it's a list of file message yep
okay
so this will be
a
list of file file message
cool yep okay I think this looks
good uh cool and then the example inputs
are what gets used uh in the API for API
usage uh so let's uh let's fix that so
this will be a
text
hello and then files will be just an
empty list for now okay cool cool cool
cool so I think these are all the
backend changes that we need to make uh
there might be some bugs here uh but
that's the fun of it that's part of the
fun uh so now let's go to the front end
so um you know similar to the back end
what the front end directory contains
when you template of a component is like
the literal chapot component that comes
with radio um so if this is the first
time seeing this it might be a little
bit overwhelming but you know bear with
me um I think it's it's it's actually
not not that not that tough um
so this is uh the way that the front end
components are structured typically is
that there's an index. spelt file so
that is like the top level of the chap
of the components frontend
implementation uh and there's typically
a couple like helper components uh in
the shared uh directory um that get
called within the index that's felt or
within other files here um and maybe
maybe I should back up um what what all
this is all that all that you're seeing
on the screen here is um is spelt so
spelt is a front-end uh it's a library
for creating front-end components um uh
like I said at the beginning of the
video I am not a front-end developer uh
but I've found it uh pretty fun to start
writing spel and start messing with
these components once you get the hang
of it um there's a slight learning curve
but you know after you know a couple
hours at most I think you guys should be
okay and hopefully this video is helping
helping you guys ease that that learning
curve um right so um you know maybe
enough Preamble let's start coding these
things will uh explain themselves
hopefully um but okay so similar to the
back end um what I want to do in the
front end first is uh change the types
here because like if you see here um
every frontend component has a value
basically and the value has a typee and
the type is the type that's sent from
the back end so you can see here this is
like the old type which is like a string
or like all this stuff right so um what
we're going to do let me uh copy this
um uh I'm G to modify this utils file to
um create some some types here that we
could use from our other components so
um let me just look at this file message
and multimodal message okay so uh
export type file
message yes that is what we want and
then this will be a
file which is file
data oh and then it'll be alt
text alt text yep which is a
string and then we're going to do this
cool and then export type
uh what did I call
it um multimodal
message mul
mod message cool okay so you don't have
to have the names line up or anything
but just you know for consistency and
you know it's just good practice to keep
these things the same so we know they're
the same it'll be a multimodal message
so this will be a text which is a string
and then there will be a list of
files files this will be file
message this cool okie dokie so now
let's go back to the index and um let's
import that type so
import type and then this will be uh
multim modal message from sh thank you
um Okay so uh let's change the type here
so this will I this will
be a multimodal message or n and yeah so
this is like a it'll be like a list of T
PS like the back end so it'll be a
multimodal
message or no cool um okay so now that
we changed the type I'm sure there's
going to be some problems here um okay
so this is also wrong so let's this will
be a multimodal message or no and then
this will be
mul message or okay so yeah this is so
right now our editor is rightfully
complaining that you know these things
are uh you know like it's these things
like the types are inray right uh which
makes sense because we just uh we just
changed the types so if we look at this
what this is doing so this dollar sign
um thing is spelt Syntax for like
declaring a a variable to be reactive so
what this is saying is that whenever the
value changes either because it gets
returned from a function or or whatever
um we're going to call this map
function um to like basically process
each of the messages that come back from
the the back end right uh and then
that'll get stored in this underscore
value variable okay so if we look at
this what this doing is that it's going
to map over the tupal of the user
message and the bot message and then
it's going to do um
you know basically if it's like a string
you're going to do this if it's you know
not a string you're G to do that or
something right so basically this is
using the old logic where it was either
a it was either a string or a file so
now that it can be both um we need to
take care of that so what I'm going to
do is I'm just going to um create a new
function so let's call it
function process
messages uh or process message um so
this will take a message which is of
typed multimodal message or no and then
it'll return a multimodal message or
no oh okay
so um if message is null just going to
return the
message need some parentheses
here okay and then what we're going to
do is we're basically just going to call
these uh functions that already exist
here um otherwise so message. text is
going to be uh redirect SRC URL message.
text and then uh not me so message.
files is going to be message. files map
normalized
messages yep I think this is
okay cool cool cool process message um
and then what we're going to do here is
we're just going to call this function
there so what we're going to do is we're
going to return process message user
message process message B message cool
okay so uh that is pretty good
progress um me back up a little bit okay
so then now What's Happening Here is
that um the index that spell file is you
know delegating you know the actual
rendering of the chatbot to this chatbot
component uh so obviously this has the
old value type uh now that we change it
it's it's complaining uh but before we
fix that maybe it makes sense to kind of
talk a little bit about what's happening
here in this index SW file um so you
know similar or right let me back up uh
so basically every index as SP file is
going to have this one thing called the
block and the block is like the basic
like rendering you know block that's why
it has that name of the gradio UI so
that's what uh kind of like makes sure
that all the components kind of like
render within like the box that you see
them render in in in cor gradio um and
they all take you know they all take
these these properties here like scale
mean width height all that stuff um the
other thing that every index file will
have is going to be this thing called
like the status tracker and the loading
status um so this is basically what uh
you know like the the spinning animation
that you see when a component is being
output by a function and like the
processing is happening in the server
you see that like progress animation
that's basically what this data stor is
doing right so every component's going
to have that so when you see it don't be
scared not that you would be scared I
guess but but uh yeah just kind of you
can you can pretty much leave it as is
um and then yeah like the the label is
usually in this block label thing um and
it takes an icon right so if you look
here you know there's like an icon
library that you you can use uh in your
custom component as well uh but
basically we don't have to touch any of
this because we like how the normal
chatbot renders we're just changing a
little bit about like the data
processing uh so we can leave most this
as is but you know if you do want to
change a little bit about how component
looks uh you can do that um you know by
modifying the code
basically um cool so let's go to this
chat bot and let's
fix the data issue so um let's let's
import the type of uh import type uh
multimodal message from
utils um and then similar to what we did
in index. spelt this will be a
multimodal message or all and then this
will be a multimodal message
orinal okay and then here we go multi
modal message or no and then same thing
here
cool um okay so let's see is there other
stuff
happing yeah okay so it's complaining
obviously about the type being wrong so
message so this will be handle select so
yeah so let's change this to a
multimodal
message um change this to multim mobile
message cool um okay so now let's go
back down
here okay
so let's kind of walk through a little
bit about what's happening here so um
basically if the message is a string you
render like a markdown of the message
and then if the message is actually a
file um what we're going to do is just
basically render like a video or like a
media component for that M type that
corresponds on that M type so if it's an
audio render an audio component if it's
a video render a video component
component all that stuff right so what
we're going to want to do
is um always render the markdown message
and then for Loop over the files and
then render uh basically keep this and
then you know render the um yeah render
all the the components that are in the
files
key um hopefully that makes sense uh
when I start doing it it I hope it I
think it will make a lot more sense
right so we're going to get rid of that
is because we're we're going to have a
text message going to move that a little
bit back and then what we're going to do
is that in spelt you do um dollar sign
each for so for
each file
in
message
files as actually is this the right
syntax let me uh check
actually I always uh always get confused
that's the right what the right syntax
is um
so let me
verify
each okay I think it is f
a um okay so what we're going to do is
basically bring all the stuff in here
if else if
message
okay and I'm not sure about this button
thing
button
okay yeah we're just going to keep it as
is so um let uh just going to bring this
in uh for each bring that in there okay
so um is this the
right oh it's uh hashtag
if so um if uh file is not
null and
file uh file file mind type includes
audio
so wondering if I usually like my co uh
the editor like kind of picks up on the
type differences I'm wondering if I get
broke something
um oh okay so this is wrong here because
needs to be
message. text because text is a message
and then I believe this has to be called
message so do that and
then wondering what's going on here um
okay
so uh this looks good else if message
and then
file file M type includes
video do that LF message and then the
sorry this is wrong it's file
file and then file all text oh not file
one file um okay so
file F and then do the same thing
here right always going to
have I think that's fine prob leave it
as so file file
URL and file alt
text and
then
if
okay
[Music]
so what is this complaining about maybe
this is what
my that's not
open each each
[Music]
so oh and then I need to close the L so
I understand so I need to close
the here okay cool okay so now that I
did that things are uh message
text message files uh so let's see
message pair message is a multimodal
message for each file
in message files so this is a
string multi modal
message oh sorry what happened is that I
was doing some
uh I was doing some python syntax there
see like I said I'm not a really a front
end guy but um you know that doesn't
stop you from making or trying to make a
a gradio custom component um yeah so
message file okay so this looks good
okay so if message and message oh yes so
okay so obviously this thing is breaking
now file file
URL and then this will be file file
URL
um file file or name file file
path um
okay I think that's is probably
okay um or this I mean this this whole
message here
um okie
dokie so I'll tell you what I think I
feel pretty good about this so this
makes me feel like we've
done most of the here we've we're we've
kind of done as much as we can without
actually trying to run this so let's
let's run this so let's go to our demo
and then um I'm going to do right so
yeah the demo basically what it's doing
it's like it's rendering a uh you know
an interactive and non-interactive
multimodal chatot I don't know what we
have this whole comma here I don't think
we need this at all actually so let me
just remove
this um and
then I don't think we need this either
so
okay uh let me go back to the terminal
right so uh once you've you know made
sufficient modifications to the code or
before you can run this demo in a
development mode uh to see if if your
code is working right so what
development mode does is that it spins
up the gradio front end and the gradio
back end in an environment where changes
to the code are reflected automatically
so you don't have to like restart the
server or anything so it helps you know
iterate a lot faster on on these
components um okay so uh the way you do
that is you do groc Dev
okay so let's
see cool okay so it's
working um it's opening here my other
laptop let me try to bring
it
um okay so I'm just gonna give me a
second
sorry I'm just going to new tab open
this
here cool cool cool okay so so it's not
loading probably means that there's a
mistake somewhere so let's figure it
out I properties of undefined reading
text where is this happening in chatbot
line 126 okay so let's go to the chatbot
line
126 um that's probably
wrong um let go back to um reading
text uh new
chatbot
here let me go back to the
demo as
sample nothing here okay so it's
probably just a mistake in the front end
let's try to figure it out so go back to
the
code so cannot read properties of
[Music]
um
value process
message uh I wonder if it's like a
backend thing
so pre-process of payload turn that
postprocess
none
proper okay
okay let's
see another
message conso
okay not repr oh new
chat let's see
okay
no
message so uh this will be
a let's try to fix the types here
multimodal message
n okay so maybe this is what was
happening
so okay yeah so maybe this is what was
happening noriz
messages multimodal
message okay yeah so the
file is a file message okay yeah so this
is sorry this is a file
message and this will return a file
message
okay okay this looks good message
text
um to the console
can find reading
text
okay this uh can I read
properties interesting
okay so I think what's probably
happening is that the
um it's probably happening is that the
the value is none so let's go to the
demo the value is none or somewhere the
value is none and
then um it's uh not liking it because
I'm somewhere I'm assuming that it's not
uh not none so I'm just trying to think
oh this is why so I'm not returning
anything the answer was staring me right
in the
face okay so let's
see Moment of
Truth oh nice okay cool see uh it's
really scary when it doesn't work it's
really fun when it does work okay so
um so awesome that's great so let's uh
let's test our code a little bit more so
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
like simulate a conversation here
um between a user and a bot where
they're like
exchanging um where they're exchanging
like files and stuff
so um so you let's see so uh user
message one is going to
be uh text and then it's going to
be um
hello what is in this image and then the
files are going to
be um whoa that's cool um I I don't want
to do that though just because I don't
know what's if that's actually a real
file um I'm just going
to uh copy a URL of a file that I do
know um so this will be a list of files
and
then uh the
file is going to be uh what I'm going to
do is from radio so basically because
the data model uses a uh a file data um
I'm just going to use that to be it'll
be easier
file file data and then the path is
going to be this URL
here I think that's good
um yeah I think that makes sense
okay um and then what we're going to do
here uh bot message one is going to be
text
TT uh it is a very cute
dog and then files will be
nothing okay and then
[Music]
conversation is going to be user message
one B message and then this has to be a
list of
lists so that's what we're going to do
and then we're going to use
conversation um
okay so did it
work oh
nope n tape has no attribute expand tabs
okay so let
me file text so this is coming from we
look
here expand tab so I'm pretty sure
that's
coming it's coming from our back
end
expand tabs interesting um okay so for
f let's
see
okay let me read the message
again and type object has no attribute
expand tabs
I wonder where it's getting called
from um let's go to our demo and make
sure that the right thing
file file
[Music]
data I think this is the right thing
let's
see X Files list file message yep
um
is it uh oh
maybe the way that I wrote it I'm
assuming that the alt text is always
present let's see all
text
um let's see post
process
next
message
I wonder if it's this line here so let
me just comment that out we'll see what
happens the error goes away change
detective so I think that did fix the
error no it
didn't
oops
see so there is an error here so it's
not
this go back to to the
[Music]
demo oh test
text damn
okay oh there we go cool so hello what
is in this image it is a dog awesome so
that worked uh so it's probably better
it would probably be better to do a um
to like actually import the data model
class that way we get like a helpful
prentic error um
but um let us continue so user message
two so text um let's see um
describe this
audio
clip please let's be nice
ni um
files so this will be a
file file data and then what I'm going
to do actually um so we did a URL here
let me just pass a local file um so let
me uh just do that real
quick um over here in this other
component or this other terminal
actually so CP sources gradius
um uh gradio demo yes uh audio debuger I
think and then ca. web I'm going to pass
it to sources
components um multi modal chat
boot
demo cool uh so let me uh go back let me
just put this over there um okay
so file data so the pth in this case so
you can see here I put it in the demo
ca. we so the path here is uh it'll
actually be demo Das Cantina wav because
we're running this from the top level
not the demo directory so uh can. wav oh
actually did some crazy stuff there
um actually it's easier to not use cop
pod in this case so
file close that close that close that
okay and then the bot's going to
say can type B message
to
text it is the cona song from Star
Wars
okay and
then no
files so now let's add that to our
conversation so user message 2 B message
uh change detected okay so I'm
hopefully it reloaded so hello what is
in this image cute dog describe this
audio
clip it I don't know if you guys can
hear that but it's like the Cana song
from Star Wars and the bot is smart
enough to know that um okay and then the
last thing we'll do is a video so um
user message three and this time rather
than the user sending a a
um a file let's have the bot return a
file just to show that that works too uh
give me a
video clip
please and then you know user will not
send any files and then uh bot message
three uh text here's a video clip of the
world uh file and then let me just do
the same thing let me just copy over a
file
um real
quick
radio so I'm just copying something from
the
um from the gradio repo of the test file
that I use a lot in the gr
repo
sources Okay so
let's go back here so files this will be
a list
and uh it'll
be a
file file data path so you can see the
video world that MP4 so demo world. MP4
okay cool
beans okay so by message three and then
actually you know what let's just send
you know two files back uh why not just
to show that we could display more than
one file per
message um
file file
data uh let's just send the cantina song
back again
canina and
then okay so then let's add that to our
conversation so user message three B
message three
uh change
detected no
errors nice okay so give me a video clip
here's a video clip of the world you can
play it nice and
then you can play the clip cool
so um good job us uh good job team uh
yeah so you know there are a couple bugs
there we have to figure out but you know
that's usually how it goes so it's not
going to work the first first time even
if you work on gradio every day you're
still going to make mistakes um so it's
just a matter of persevering I guess uh
but yeah but you know that being said
though if you run into any trouble that
you can't figure out uh feel free to ask
on the hugging face Discord in the gro
Channel follow an issue um about things
we can improve about this because
obviously we want to make this as easy
as possible so okay so now I'm pretty
happy with this um let me change this
back to um not use demo uh actually
because I want to deploy this to hugging
face in which case um you know like the
the files are going to be in the same
directory as where the server is being
loaded from so let me just yes it's
going to complain that I can't find the
file which is expected okay so um after
you've done implementing your component
uh what you do is you build it so you do
radio CC
build let me actually uh make this yeah
radio CC build uh so what that that is
going to do is um it's going to like
build the component so it's going to
package all the front end code and
create a wheel which is the standard
python package distribution file format
um of your component right so um so the
wheels located in the disc directory so
we do this uh here we see that there is
a wheel for a multimodal chatbot and it
there is a um The Source
distribution cool so uh could send this
you know to anyone you could pip install
this um actually yeah um let me just
show that real quick so python demo
app.py oh let me just CD into demo so
that it works python uh app.py so once
you build it you don't you can run it
outside of De mode so um let's go check
that out
so hooray yep awesome okay so basically
once you build it um you know you can
run it wherever you want want uh and
then you could also send this file to
any one of your friends your colleagues
uh they can just pip install like they
could do pip install disc oh I'm in the
wrong directory uh pip install
disc um and then uh the wheel file and
then they'll have this and they can use
this component in any gradio app uh
right but um rather than you having to
send this file manually to people it'd
be way easier if you could just sh
upload this to pipie so that anyone can
install it with Pip and it'd be really
cool if you could just like deploy it to
hugging pH immediately so that anyone
can check out your component uh so that
is what we're going to do now um so uh
after you build it only after you've
built it uh you can do gradio CC publish
so what this will do is it'll walk you
through the the process of publishing uh
to pipie and to hugging face so um here
it's explaining that if you upload it to
ppie you can install with Pip install so
that's what we're going to do so it's
asking me if if I want to upload it to
piie yes I do and then what's needed is
a username or a password uh so you can
create an account here uh my account my
account actually has two Factor
authorization so I'm not going to log in
with my standard username and password
I'm going to log in with an API token so
uh username token let me go
get
um let me go get my API token right
now so yeah so this supports tofa
awesome I authenticated so I'm uploading
the wheel and the source distribution to
pipie um so this is
uh it's on pipie now I think that's
super cool so anyone can run this line
and get this component and use them use
it in their in their gradio app so I
think that's really cool uh and then
it's you know uh you know saying that
you know if you upload talk spaces you
know anyone can use it without having to
install it right so people who don't
people who don't don't know python
people don't know how to code can use my
multimodal chatback component so I want
to do that so I'm going to say yes uh
all right so then the way that it's um
works is that it tells you to you know
point it to a demo directory so um by
default it'll use the demo directory
that you use throughout the the
development process so I'm just going to
leave it blank to signify that I want to
use that demo directory you can
obviously change it if you want and then
it's also asking if I want to upload the
source code I do want to upload the
source code and then I'm just going to
use the current directory because that
contains source code uh so it's updating
it's uploading all all of our files it's
uploading our wheel um and cool now they
got
updated so it's building my hugging face
space of my multimodal chatbot component
so spe this up in the
edit
cool um but yeah but our component is on
pii so it's really cool you get a
basically installed in any hugging face
space or on collab or um anywhere really
so any computer basically has an
internet access and pip installed um
okay so now we started cool it's working
nice okay so then here is our little
chatbot
component everything plays beautifully
this is so awesome nice okay so I hope
you enjoyed this tutorial uh definitely
something new for me so let me know if
there's any feedback uh for how we can
make this better um we definitely want
to make it better um if I can uh but
yeah but this is really cool right so
this is you know like our our custom
multimodal chatbot um and then what
we're going to do in a subsequent video
is build like a custom text box in which
you can submit both text and file
attachments simultaneously so that you
could make use of this component so uh
stay tuned for part two I hope you
enjoyed this tutorial again and um yeah
talk to you guys uh or see you guys soon